Zusa Aizawa, 27 years old, single, single woman
, lived only for company work.
Lost momentum
[Applause]
I'm dead.
However, in the next life, I will make sure that you can live a happy life
.
Is it okay if I don't have to? I don't mind if it
's the
ox of Janni Is it something that can be done easily?
That's all it takes.The goal is to live a slow life for a long time.Okay,
let's block and relax and reincarnate in the
plateau.In any case, let's choose the representative.
]
I can't read Japanese, but if anyone wants an aid I can give it to
you My dog
I wonder if that goddess prepared it for me
This is me
Yes, I'm definitely 17 years old It's pretty cute
This forehead is like a witch I
was reborn in a secret hot spring
I'm no longer in shock From now on, it's not just a word, it's the
heat, the opponent draws
And I was
here from today
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh  Ah, ah, I
'm
pretty sure it's a different world,
isn't it?
[Music
] There's a lot of amazing things Hmm, that's an
unfamiliar face.
It's
not big, but it's a beautiful village
Youko-san to the road patrol guild What
makes this village peaceful? Monsters are like slimes too.  I'm sorry, but
I defeated it halfway through. I just got it
. It's a magic stone.
Witch Level 1 Yes, I was a
witch in my head.  I'd like a guild to
secure my source of income
From that day on, my slow life began.
It's a good source of income, so I kill at least 25 of them every day. I'm
a witch who used to go into the nearby forest, so I can easily find medicinal herbs.
And leisurely days
Exactly what
I'm saying A second life that seems to be Yuuji And it's 300 years Well, if you continue for hundreds of years, your level will rise a bit
Hello, witch of the plateau, tactics I heard well
Good
for hundreds of years  Well, now I'm the most knowledgeable about the history of this village
.
It's hot, I
don't feel bad, but
hello. It's going to be
5,200 gold. Thank
you.
I'm registered as an adventurer, but I've never been on an adventure,
so could you show me how you live?
You've been watching over this Ninakamura for a long time, haven't you?
That's why I think I'm sure it's a tremendous status.
It
's strange that my experience points
are 10,840,000, isn't it?
That's right, with an average of 25
witches a day From now on, she's got a special ability to increase the experience gained by her grandmother
.
The slime's basic experience is 2
, but this ability will increase it to 4. 7 day
425 kicks village only 65 Toru
Mikasui.  You can't defeat 4308, which is easy to come by dragon
.
Please don't do it
Why don't you?
Don't tell anyone I
want to live quietly and quietly.
I can't even believe that
I defeated a Ki Slime before,
so it's okay to have that number, use it haha ​​yeah yeah yeah it
was a hot day
go and make use of it Before I
knew it I remembered that this magic is super  Convenient, the
answer is to use magic from other gardens.
[Music] It's an
honor, isn't it? You're Azusa, the witch of the plateau.
I'm a witch who makes a small living by taking things.I
heard that there's a level 99 witch
here.Hey, it's on the 5th floor.  So my ability is at most level 10,
air level 3 Moon a. It's useless even if I put hydrogen on it. Your body
is overflowing with magical
power.
Yes, if I bought
it, go around saying that the witch of the highlands wasn't a big deal If I can do it, I
don't want to fight.
O wind, now is the time to become the nest of the clear sky.
I didn't use it to
say so why yes?
The rumors were true, wasn't it?
Uka, you're a majoko, and a
dragon has
come.  I don't want to say that I'm the
same
, I'm buying more and more volumes At least I'm human.
I don't think it's black and white, and
I don't like it.  So if I'm weak, please take it easy It
's okay if I can confirm that I'm the strongest too That's fine
.  It seems like it's true I've had a lazy
capo project for 4 days
me
tan
ah ah ah My
head is a teen's spoon
tee
I
had a pod
[music]
me
snubbach hi  Even if I go in, I'm still in a state of slurred
Hey, Dragon Lykatan Please fix my house
, I don't think I
'll forgive
you
Is it okay if I eat it?
You've defeated the witch-sama dragon.
It's a room, isn't it? I'm a room at an inn
.
There are a lot of people in the village who have been saved by the witch
[music] It
's not bad
to fall for her kindness once in a while
.
In other words, 9 sales are the best, is
n't it
?  By the way, I'm sorry, but there was someone who wanted to meet the witch, but
I apologize for the inconvenience caused yesterday
.
I'm the Red Dragon from yesterday.
I have a request for you.
It's up to you to throw away your arrogance
and want to provide it from the city
Its true name is beautiful, but I didn't become strong at a 2nd cafe.
I overestimated my power as a dragon
, became arrogant, and didn't hone my skills
.
Please, I want to learn about the life of a
witch.I'm a live-in child
, so she cooks and cleans.Yes, of
course.
Thank
you.By the way, Leica is
300 years old.It's almost 300 years old.
If you don't
mind it, it's better to add more
.
Together with the car,
then
Creature
[music]
4 e
Today is already over.
Let's go back to
that.
Raikov:
That's
not the point of absolutely not falling in love with Noah
, right
?  So don't use it too much
Look, it's getting dark,
isn't
it?  I want you to protect that,
I understand
First of all
, I will do as you say So, if you get tired from now on or think that
you can't do it anymore, you'll have a lot of fun.
[Music]
Ah,
this is complete, do
you like it?
Hey, 300 yen since I started reincarnating as a witch It's my first time, so I'm starting a lower life I'm not a rattle like I'm trying to do right now
Character cars that stand in my way
I'll meet you until I'm the proprietress of chan